an emergency declaration for iowa
who had an incredible windstorm like
probably they've never seen before
it really did a lot of damage so i've
informed the governor i've informed
senator grassley and senator joni ernst
so i've approved the declaration
emergency declaration for
iowa and we are heading now
to a combination of different places we
may
do a a surprise visit we'll make it
i'll say this a surprise visit to iowa
and we can get it in we're going to do
that
but the very important thing is that we
approve the emergency declaration for
iowa
so they're in good shape they're they're
working as we
as we speak also fema is in iowa now
full force
and helping them greatly okay mr
president
oleandra the potential therapy for
coronavirus is that something you're
pressing the fda to approve
you'd have to say it oleandran has have
you heard of that as a possible therapy
for
i've heard of it yes go ahead press the
fba no i haven't
i have it is it something you would
support is it something that people are
talking
about very strongly we'll look at it
we'll look at it we're looking at a lot
of different things
i will say the fda has been great they
are very close we're very close to a
vaccine very close to a therapeutic
i've heard that name mentioned we'll
find out i can get back to you later
okay
it's possible we're trying to work it
into the schedule i want to see the
people
i love the people of iowa they've been
very loyal and the big thing was
getting the declaration signed but i'll
be going very soon and maybe today
situation yeah it's terrible
that's a terrible situation belarus
uh we'll be following it very closely
we'll be followed
we're gonna look at that we've been
asked that question brazilian students
coming back in we're looking at it very
close
we're looking at the brazilian situation
we'll take care of all of them
okay so we'll see you in a little while
yeah
[Music]
what's your goal well we're going to be
stopping at a number of places
we'll be uh working very hard
uh it doesn't have to be covered but it
probably will be
you know but we're gonna be working very
hard stopping in various states you have
a list of the states
uh pretty comprehensive we're gonna be
working very hard
we have to we're getting down to final
crunch
we want to be there as an example iowa
just came up
we're doing well in iowa it just came up
i want to be with the people of iowa so
we add that to the schedule
uh probably uh on friday we're looking
at friday
and uh we may do just a small service
right here in the white house
for my brother we're looking at doing
that that would be
i think a great honor to him i think
he'd be greatly honored he loves our
country he loved our country so much
he was so proud of what we were doing
and what we are doing for our country so
i think it would be appropriate so we
will have probably
on friday afternoon a small service in
honor of
my brother robert
[Music]
any update on stimulus
no i think this i think that uh nancy
pelosi and
chuck schumer should get back into
washington and they should
approve stimulus for the people they
should give
we should give some of this was china's
fault it wasn't their fault
and we'd like to see payment going to
the people maybe ppe
but we want pay payment going to the
people
we'll take care of the post office we
want to make sure
that the post office runs properly and
it hasn't run properly for many years
for
probably 50 years it's run very badly
so we want to make sure that the post
office runs properly
and does it lose billions of dollars
somebody said it lost 78 billion dollars
over a
relatively short period of time that's
over years
78 billion dollars so you can't have
that no
we will work with them but we want money
to go to the people that need it
and they don't want to do that they just
want to take care of the
bailout money they want bailout money to
go to their friends that are doing a bad
job running democrat
states if you have states that are
losing
a lot of money they've been poorly run
by democrats for many years
and that's all they want to talk about
is bailing out those states
that's unfair to the rest of the country
are going to affect are you worried
about cutbacks through service affecting
people getting medication
and prescriptions no no the post office
is running very well
the post office now look if you look at
the post office
for years that's all people complained
about we're going to run it well and
we're gonna not
lose so much money one of the things the
post office
loses so much money on is delivering
packages
for amazon and these others every time
they deliver a package they probably
lose three or four dollars
that's not good they have to raise those
prices okay
not for the people to pay but for amazon
and those companies to pay for it
thank you very much on mail-ins
on mail-in ballots why are you opposed
to mail-in ballots when they cannot be
packed by foreign interest or reference
absentee ballots are great
you request a ballot you can't be i
signed an absentee ballot
absentee ballots are great they work
they've been proven they're good like in
florida
but this universal mail-in is a very
dangerous thing
it's fraught with fraud and every other
thing that can happen
and we have to be very very careful we
have a very big election coming up
i think we're going to do very well and
i want to make sure the election is not
stolen
and so does everybody else and i'm sure
both sides feel that way
so we have to be very careful with this
universal mail-in ballot
absentee ballots are great they've
worked for a long time
and i i totally endorse absentee ballots
thank you very much
the postmaster general a big donor to
you to slow the mail
no not at all wouldn't do that no i i
have
encouraged everybody speed up the mail
not slow the mail
and i also want to have a post office
that runs without losing
billions and billions of dollars a year
as it has been doing for
50 years thank you that's the nail if
you're removing machines if you remove
the machines mr president and the boxes
foreign